Hey guys! I-it's me.
I've got the same haircut as you now
(K-pop members laugh)
Oh you dont care!?
I-I see, It's cause I'm Swedish, isn't it?
K-pop
I-is a wonderful thing that happened to... the world
Clearly I haven't drawn any...form of ...i-inspiration from-from k-pop at all.
Clearly I don't want to be G-Dragon
More than anything else in life
I'm gonna show you...
Some k-pop...
That will change your life
♬  K-pop song plays ♬
What?
What is this?
That's some pretty deep lyrics right there man
Really makes me...
The
The Koreans have evolve their species
Above writing lyrics
They...*laughs*
Well, let me see if I can...let me see if I can do it.
*sounds exactly like song, there is no difference*
♬ Song continues♬
Is it weird that I secretly like it?
♬ Song kinda sounds like a mixture of cats whining with a sick beat ♬
*Sick dance move break*
Is this (the) "Try Not to Get Annoyed" challenge?
Jesus Christ
How am I supposed to sit through this whole thing?
♬ Orange Caramel - Catallena ♬
Are they sushi?
Oh, okay
Is that what they're singing about?
I've been with some...
Some shank women before but,
Man they, they
They really shove it in their face
♬  BTS - Not Today ♬
I like how they mix a little bit of English in there
It makes me feel included
Appreciate ya
OHHH~!
HAA!
This guy's my favourite
I dunno how you can you make this part look cool
Like what the fuck are they doing?
♬ Today we will survive♬
Ahh~
If you haven't creamed your pants already
then I don't know what you're doing here...
Hey crow tits, hands up
Is that what they're saying?
Hey crow tits, hands up?
That's good lyrics
That's just good writing
Are they really saying "hey crow..." *laughs*
Finally...
Not all these Americanized shitty lyrics
They... Koreans got the lyrics
you know from the *"sings" the first song*
to "hey crow tits hands up"
Uhh
Amazing
Honestly...
the music isn't really my forte
It's a bit too dance for me, okay
The thing is I wanna love BTS so bad, because goddamn
#1 - They're goddamn beautiful
#2 - Those choreographies
Goddamn
How did they do that
It makes me feel things...
as a man that I didn't know I was capable of feeling
It makes me question my soul
My sexuality
and my very being
Who am I?
Why am I here?
and why did my dick inflate a little bit?
It's never done that before
My god
#3
The visuals are so fucking cool in these videos, like
They're incredible
How do they make dancing look cool?
Dancing, the lamest fucking thing in the universe
*in some weird gruff voice* The- they make it look cool
How is that possible?
It's not fair man!
It should not be like that
That's not... they're cheatinggggg
It's like Goddamn!
Goddamn!
The thing is-
The thing is like
I think-
You know,
You got the
UK version
Which is like
Fucking One Direction or whatever
They don't dance
Okay
They're too cool to dance
Because they can't fucking dance like BTS
Ain't nobody dances like BTS!
And let me tell you
Uh
Even their clothes are cool, okay
It's not fair!
I was born,
in the wrong country! Damn you Sweden!
The thing that I realized is
Okay
D-don't hold this against me, okay
This might hurt
Individually...
They're not that attractive
A-bup-di-je-bep-
But as a group
T-this weird thing happens
where they just become like...
BAAH !
SEVEN TIMES MORE ATTRACTIVE
And you're like AHHHHHHH~!!
It's not fair!
It's just not fair!
How that does math work!?
You know, that- that statement about them not being attractive individually
I may have to retract that statement
I've just seen this video
I like men now.
This just in-
I LIKE MEN NOW
Also uh... *pls dont tell marzia*
You know ...
To be honest, I don't really like their music that much
I-I-I-I-
I like the videos
'cause they're so visual
and they work really- it compliments their music really well.
Ah, this song I do like
Quite a bit, It's pretty good
It's pretty.. It's
I'm not gonna lie, It's pretty gay
♬ Spring Day by BTS ♬
Why am I making this video at this point?
I made this video originally
to try make fun of k-pop
I can't do it...
This is...
100%
The most pathetic video
I've ever done
Clearly anyone else reacting to Kpop is like
"Well this is pretty gay"
Me reacting to Kpop:
"Well I'm gay"
*laughs*
Maybe me and Jack could do it
Jack is coming here this week
Jack!
Uh..want to start a k-pop band with me?
You know,
both me and Jack, moderately attractive men
but add us together
BAAH!!!!
*scream in background* This could work
This could work
Now, I haven't gotten started on G-Dragon
I-I can't even talk about it
it.. it gets too much
Now let's uh..let's watch some more other k-pop
♬ ♬
There's also cat k-pop
Which is uh...
Let's just watch it
So that's a thing, in case uh...
In case anyone is interested,
you know if you like cats
I think you'll like er...
I think you like this shit
Of course there's a
k-pop
sneezing compilation
WOW SO SEXY!!
Did you hear the sneeze?
*cheering*
AHAHA
Amazing
Incredible
But my favourite
Wait-
Let's watch my favourite
It's so fucking good
This woman's sneeze-
She knew
She knows
how attractive this sneeze is
Watch
She's like oh it's comin'
It's comin'
Oh I gotta pu- Are people watching?
Yes they are
WOOOH
A sneeze
everyone!
WOOOOOOOOOOOH
What else could they sing about this point, they've...
they've done it all!
OOOOOOOH
It's a song about...
Broccoli
Okay
I realized I'm supposed to make fun of this desperate
incredibly cring-ey woman
but at the same time
I wish I was her
Oh okay
well that's enough of that
It's not fair
Why was I born with this Swedish skin?
You know what?
fuck it,
I'm starting my own k-pop band, from now on
Fuck YouTube
Fuck Buzzfeed
and
FUCK
ME~
I got it
A SUPER SWEET
That's all you need.
A.S.S.
Thank you for supporting,
A.S.S is coming
A.S.S is coming out
I repeat A.S.S is comin
It's gonna take over the world
with the Swedish k-pop
Leave a like to die instantly
and I'll see you guys in the next video
As always, stay awesome bros